good morning everybody and welcome to
environment and agriculture we will
start the day today with a work session
on
HB 56 and HB 253
let's start this morning with the Pledge
of Allegiance led by Lisa smart
representative smart
congratulations to the flag of the
United States of America
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
foreign
so this morning uh
we would like to do some work with our
committee to discuss uh some amendments
that have been brought forward for HB
253 and HB 56 and why don't we start out
with HB 253 establishing a committee to
study extended producer responsibility
and I believe
representative Murray you have the
amendment which was put forth by
representative Bixby who unfortunately
cannot be here today
due to illness although I understand he
may be listening from home so good
morning representative Bixby
uh thank you madam chair yes so um what
you have before you is the original
Amendment um HB
um to HB 253 which is 20230776h
basically as we had discussed initially
um we had three members named to the
House of Representatives appointed by
the speaker and instead of two members
there is one member as we discussed in
our last work session
um we also then in lines 11 through 13
included the
um
statement that we should be reducing the
tax burden that Solid Waste Disposal
places on municipalities that was added
in there as well there is a scrivener's
error on line 14 that says exam it is
meant to say examining or examine
existing eprs epr laws and so that
includes States territories and
international jurisdictions and
establish priorities for more in-depth
study
and then further on line 17's asks that
we look at how ways in which laws could
be adapted to existing Solid Waste
Recovery infrastructure
and then in lines 20
um
it gives the study committee the
authority to solicit industry
stakeholder input on approaches
suggest possible legislation and then
also propose targeted study legislation
for approaches to adopt in the future
um and that also then allows the
committee to work on a broad range of
stakeholder with a broad range of
stakeholders and have them at the table
okay thank you representative you had a
question
I do thank you madam chair
um
my question is it says propose more
specifically targeted legislation
um which says that you're going to
actually propose legislation wouldn't
that say may propose or could propose uh
instead of saying that you're actually
going to propose I'm just asking
no I think that's a fair point uh
representative
um I think the goal is to
um
put forward potential pieces of
legislation so that we can work side by
side with those in the solid waste
working group as well as then to have
input from stakeholders
um
from the Department
okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
well
um
I believe that uh
you know we we had discussed uh in in
the previous
a discussion about this
Amendment
um that both line 22 and 24 was going to
be saying suggesting rather than
proposing okay so I don't know if we
would have time to
I'm certainly happy to uh look to see if
I could get that word changed from uh
from proposed to suggest in line 24 yeah
is that is that the question
if I can I'm happy to or representative
how would you want to word that
differently and since
thank you madam chair sorry about that
um it says here suggests possible
legislation and or rules for
implementing approaches and then I think
it should be May propose or could
propose but proposing means that it's
definitely going to happen where it
doesn't necessarily have to happen we
could suggest we can do that I mean so
22 and 23 really take care of that
entire section if you think about it
okay
so
um you would want to add in the word may
before the word propose on line 24.
representative come tomorrow okay
uh thank you
um so I'm just wondering if line 22 and
then line 24 are very similar
um because I think they're kind of
redundant in a way because line 22 says
suggest possible legislation and or
rules for implementing approaches that
would be readily adaptable to New
Hampshire and then it goes proposed more
specifically targeted study legislation
um but if we're going to already suggest
possible legislation or rule changes do
we really need that line in there yeah
so I I agree I think that probably line
24 and 25 could be just eliminated
representative Dotsy
um you know I I was reading that and I
and I I think
um I had to read it several times to
understand it but I think the first one
uh line 22 is suggesting possible
legislation and then line 24 is proposed
proposed more specifically targeted
study legislation so the one is uh
suggest possible legislation which I
understand could come out of that and
then I think what they're also saying is
because this is such you know a broad
and and difficult subject that they want
to propose more uh more targeted study
legislation so another study committee
may come out of that so I think that's
the difference and you don't see that uh
line 22 and 23 would cover that you know
representative thank you madam chair
um I also know that we also have a solid
waste working group that works on all of
these issues and I don't think that this
particular group needs to worry about
that because the solid waste working
group which encompasses a lot a much
broader scope of things could come
before people or do the suggestion or
proposing
representative Howard
the way that I think about him chair and
the way that I read it um it seems like
20 line 22 number five
is talking about
um uh either legislation or rules and
rules being a different you know coming
from a different source so that I think
that is a an important distinction
um and also that that number six on line
24 and 25 they're talking about looking
further forward to legislate things that
are difficult so the first one is
readily uh implemented and the other is
difficult to implement and I think that
um it's not unfair to ask them to to
have two deliverables
representative nebb
thank you madam chair I mean I just want
to agree with that I think um to the
point you've made in past conversations
there will be things that are easy to
tackle and there will be things that
will be much more complicated and I view
it as line 22 is is speaking to those
things that are sort of late low-hanging
fruit in terms of starting to work on
um producer responsibility and line 24
is is acknowledging that there are going
to be these more complicated items that
will require further study
thank you
representative Murray
um
oh I sure had a question
well go ahead representative Creighton
thank you ma'am
um
yeah the way I read this is a study is a
subset of legislation and if you put
legislation in on 22 then study is
inherently part of it and it's up to the
committee to decide how they want to
deal with that whether they want to
recommend a study legislation or where
they want to recommend a
specific act I think I think six in my
my opinion is that sick could probably
go away line 24 and 25 and still be
covered in five
representative Contour
thank you madam chair
um I agree and I think that because
we're trying this report is due out
November 1st to have suggest possible
legislation and what they're going to be
studying and then to more Target I mean
you're you're actually broadening the
scope of what they're doing in in a
limited amount of time I think
it was discussed that we would do the
suggest
um because we really need to focus on uh
what we could do immediately and that's
why we were forming the study committee
because to take some of the workload off
of the solid working group
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair um would it be agreeable if uh
based on the comments that we were
hearing
to Simply say at the end of line 23 and
may propose uh topics for further study
yeah that sounds fine would would that
be agreeable
if I can get that changed okay yep
and then removing lines 23 or it's 24
and 25. yes okay
and change the word examine and then if
they can get an amendment uh done for us
by the time we come back for exec
session I hope maybe we'll do my very
best okay
any other questions or comments about
this particular Amendment
seeing none I think we can move on to uh
uh we could move on to uh HB 56 and talk
about the amendment for that
so um
hang on one minute
okay
um so for HB 56 there's also an
amendment being brought forward
um
by representative Murray
and I'd like her to explain that to the
committee
everybody has copies of that by the way
correct okay thank you
Amendment zero seven seven two h
um
I wanted to based on the conversations
that we had last week regarding hb602
which we have retained correct Madam
chair
yes and also
um
the HB 56 which we had a work session on
um had wanted to make sure that I first
addressed that um we had a long
conversation about the ability for the
Department to have some flexibility in
being able to establish some rule-making
Authority
and I perhaps did not do um the best job
of highlighting that facet which it was
already in the original proposed
amendment you had last week
um which was um sub paragraph D lines 22
through 30. so I want to draw your
attention there
um in which it does give the um the
department some opportunities it
specifically says the department May
adopt
uh rules under RSA 541a to allow for the
use of project Improvement allowances
that may enable a project to meet the
minimum five-year setback even if it is
located less than a five-year distance
of travel estimate to a Surface body of
water
so in that to that end that was a large
part of our discussion there are things
that the department May in the rule
um making Authority determine are
beneficial and go above and beyond the
scope of what they normally see
and so I thought that that was an
important
aspect to make sure that I noted I also
wanted to draw your attention to line 30
where we had the scrivener's notation
that needed the small superscript
negative five and I had that um
clarified
I also then um listening to uh
representative
um Simon and some of the folks who were
discussing aspects of hb602 felt like
online like eight and a half through ten
that the department shall not issue a
license to a facility with a footprint
that overlies a significant sand and
gravel aquifer
so um that is one aspect that I felt was
important to make sure that we were in
the interest of water safety
okay thank you
any questions
for representative Murray
we have director wimsat with us from Des
and I would call him up please to help
answer a couple of questions I have
good morning director wimsat how are you
good morning Madam chair very well thank
you
um I I did give you a copy of this
amendment
and I wanted to get a your feedback on
uh in your thoughts about uh some of the
issues that this amendment addresses
sure um well again I for the record Mike
wimsad director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire des and thank
you I did just receive a copy of the
amendment
um
I guess uh
and I may have misunderstood it and you
may have said this representative Murray
but it sounds like the amendment has
very similar language relative to the uh
project Improvement allowances that the
original Bill had is that is that
correct yeah I just want to make sure
that I don't read anything very
different in that so I don't have
anything to offer with respect to that
portion of the amendment
um with regard to the introductory
paragraph on uh line nine
um the reference to uh not issuing a
license to any facility with a footprint
that overlies the significant sand and
gravel aquifer I think there would need
to be in some kind of a definition of
that because that that it's not clear
what that
specifically would refer to and
obviously the agency would need to know
exactly what that means if it were to
evaluate in particular permit
application to make sure that it either
did or didn't comport without
requirement
foreign
with regard to the
um
section D on line 29 it says that no
allowances shall be given for a site
where any measurement made of in-situ
soils within the property has an
undisturbed hydraulic conductivity
greater than equal to 1 times 10 to the
minus fifth centimeters per second I
think that's very similar to the
language in the introductory Bill and as
the bill in the bill is introduced and
as I think I mentioned during the
previous work session uh we have some
concerns because you could absolutely do
one in-situ sample at one location and
see a hydraulic conductivity that's
higher than that it would not
necessarily represent really have any
relationship to how long it would take
for groundwater to travel from the site
to a surface water body but if you had
that measurement in hand you'd have to
say you can't have a permit here
and I think that's a little too we feel
that's too restrictive because I think
that could
inadvertently result in
sites being eliminated that were
otherwise quite quite appropriate for
landfill
okay
I representative now
did you want to ask a question no go
ahead and then I have oh okay thank you
so is your concern
Ed um
a directional
travel in a direction that wouldn't be
toward the body of water that could be
one example but but even more more
generally
um because of the variability and the
heterogeneity of our of a for of our
soil formations in in at sites where
landfill would would be uh developed
you can absolutely I mean I I would
venture to Guess that at every single
site where a landfill is currently cited
there are soils in place that would test
out in an in-situ hydraulic conductivity
test at greater than 10 to the minus
centimeters per second at a higher
velocity than that it doesn't mean that
that is contiguous and that sub that
that there would be a meaningful
possibility that groundwater that was
you know the contaminated groundwater
contaminants in groundwater could travel
at that speed throughout their Pathway
to a surface water it's just not okay
the current situation is have a
follow-up sure do you have a suggested
change to that is that the rate of speed
is concerning to you or would you want
more test points where it would have to
be a certain number of them would reach
that rate of speed I think if you're
going to use that as a as a metric you
need to you need to require that a more
thorough analysis of the actual
pathway of the of the of the hydraulic
conductivity of the soils as a unit and
and that takes more extensive testing
and certainly more than one data point
and I think this essentially suggests
one data point would be determinative
representative Murray
rules though isn't it my understanding
that when you're taking those test
points you can determine how many of
them you're taking
certainly those kinds of tests are made
and and yes at some level someone always
has to decide how many but that's not
what this says that's that's what I'm
I'm offering my my analysis based on
what the the sentence the way I read the
sentence way I understand it and the way
I understand that sentence if an
applicant goes and takes 50 tests of
hydraulic conductivity and 49 of them
are much more
uh much less conductive than 10 to the
minus fifth centimeters per second but
one of them is greater than that then
the site is excluded from from
consideration
representative Creighton
thank you this and the rate
centimeters per second that that is
directly related to the length of time
it takes that contaminated water to
reach that three-year period
uh it's important to understand that
it's part of it's part of a groundwater
velocity equation so when you read soils
is say 10 to the minus 10 minus
centimeters per second that doesn't
automatically relate to that's the
velocity of the groundwater it's
dependent on hydraulic head difference
across two points it's dependent on um
you know a number of factors that that
that essentially determine that but so
my point at the demand for check the
follow-up so what I'm trying to get at
is
that by saying three years in the
previous paragraph on line 28
.
um what that is defining is how close we
want it to be
and then it's up to you guys to figure
out how fast that water travels based on
the soil conditions so as we took out
those last two lines
you've still got to figure out the
three-year Point absolutely yes is that
three year Point reasonable
oh is that reasonable and you know as I
think I've indicated in prior testimony
we don't know because we don't we don't
we don't have a lot of information about
him and we don't know about a future
site that might be
proposed it's just hard to say what it
would relate we don't know at this point
how many sites would be eliminated from
by a a standard like that and we just
don't know the answer to it
okay thank you
um director wimsat if you would please
describe to the committee
the kinds of rules you already have in
place
which
um
take into consideration the hydro
hydrological studies I mean you know I
guess I'm looking at
um some testimony that
um Adam Finkel had brought to the
committee regarding
um several landfills that we already
have he said the majority of landfills
at New Hampshire relies on today would
likely have passed the HB 56 test
of our state's large three large land
active landfills two of them are located
in soils where groundwater Flows at one
foot a day or less only the proposed
Alton site well he goes into that but
but he's saying that mount carvery
TurnKey Bethlehem
they all had these uh
these um
in it would have already it would have
passed the test so to speak and so I'm
thinking then that our rules that we
already have in place are adequate
enough to be safe for these landfills
am I am I wrong in that thinking well
that's a fair question I to be candid I
I don't know how anyone necessarily
unless they have access to an awful lot
of data and Analysis knows whether or
not those facilities would meet this
particular standard there's been a lot
of testimony in that regard but again I
I'm not sure
and again it said likely I don't know
how likely it is I don't know the answer
to that um I guess to answer the second
part of your question
um the the rules require
um the site specific you know or the uh
the standard setback that's been
discussed but that's a minimum and then
there's also General language that
requires that
um a complete hydrogeologic study be
conducted and that the agencies should
not approve a permit or a landfill
citing that is not protective of surface
water and groundwater and as I've
indicated earlier we we really focus on
the groundwater because the groundwater
is right there immediately at the
landfill boundary it's right you know
land groundwater is essentially
everywhere in New Hampshire right so if
you cite a landfill there's groundwater
under the landfill there's groundwater
immediately adjacent to the landfill and
we focus our protections on that I think
by default the surface waters end up
being protected because we're so focused
on groundwater protection
um and and monitoring to ensure
groundwater protection and a whole
series of procedures that occur when we
detect and increase in background
concentrations of any contaminant
immediately adjacent to a landfill that
that's really what provides that
protection for surface water because
we're if you protect the groundwater
you're protecting the surface water
essentially and and it does also require
that we make a determination that the
landfill siding is protective of surface
water but again I think in practice the
way that happens is through US ensuring
that we can protect groundwater and that
we have and that we're able to monitor
both groundwater and surface water
impacts over time on an ongoing basis
representative Murray
we have been working on something to
this end for quite some time and I think
that it is really important to remember
that what we are asking for is for this
to be set in statute versus rules just a
minimum commitment to saying that we
need to make sure that there is a level
that is the bare minimum set in statute
there are other things that may then
seek to exceed protections set forth and
rules but currently we don't have
anything set forth in statute other than
that arbitrary 200 foot setback
thank you
and director wimsat do you find that the
rules that we have in place now are they
compatible with this statute
that we're considering this bill that
we're considering the bill
um
I I guess what I'd say is that they
impose additional restrictions that are
not necessarily contained in the statute
um
so I I I'm not sure I completely
understand your questions so we're
considering this HB 56 and its Amendment
and I'm wondering whether the rules that
we currently have in place are
compatible with what we're considering
in this legislation in other words
um would we have to change significantly
the rules that we already have in order
to
abide by what we're seeking to put in
statute yes if a bill if HB 56 were to
pass and be enacted into law we would
have to significantly change the rules
to implement those very specific
requirements would the rules then be
have to have to be made more stringent
um
I think I think that they would be more
stringent I mean if we were to adopt the
specific Provisions in this they would
those rules would be more stringent yes
representative germana thank you madam
chair uh and thank you director for
taking my question I just want to follow
up on a question that was asked by uh
representative of Creighton about uh you
know would the three-year rule
um for example be uh reasonable right uh
and your answer was if I jotted this
down correctly we don't know how many
sites would be eliminated right if we
were to adopt that rule but isn't that
always the case when you have a rule I
mean isn't actually that kind of the
point of making a rule is that you don't
know ahead of time exactly how many
sites are going to be affected and
that's why the test has to be done in
the first place so whether it's a
minimum of 200 feet or if it is a
three-year rule that the same answer
would apply that we don't know uh a
priori which sites are going to be
affected and which are not
to a certain extent I think that's true
but I think in the case of this bill
um the senses it could be substantial it
could the concern that we've expressed
in the past is that without knowing for
sure how this would play out
um in in practice we don't know if it
would substantially reduce the the
number of the the availability of
available eligible sites for landfill
citing
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair director wimsat
would you agree
that there may come a time
sooner than later where a landfill site
requires
we update the rules so that we don't
have a situation that the current rules
don't cover it's an old rule and I think
we're here because there may come sooner
than later a proposed site that requires
additional protection
and to put it in statute
gives you the wherewithal to recognize
that we may need to adjust the rules
somewhat and update them for a site that
has not been
previously covered as in TurnKey carvery
and Bethlehem
if I'm understanding your your question
correctly certainly the agency believes
that continual evaluation of the rules
and how they're working and how they how
they're applied in the current situation
and prospective future situations is an
important part of what we do and what
and what the legislature does and
certainly I mean I think it's important
to understand though that
when a bill is passed if it's very
prescriptive
the agencies
discretion is basically eliminated at
that point if if the rule is very
prescriptive about how a particular
thing is implemented we just simply make
a rule that says the same thing or in
some cases we even just refer to the
statute in the rule we don't even
restate it
so it it there's a I think in some cases
folks think we're going to take
whatever's passed and then try to
interpret it and and uh and get creative
of the rules but that's not when the
rule is very prescriptive that's not
what happens we essentially Implement
that prescriptive requirement we may do
it through rulemaking but it's it's
basically taken directly verbatim from
the statute I understand I defer to my
colleagues for a follow-up
representative dutse
uh yeah I
I have been frustrated by the argument
that I have been hearing that if we pass
this law
um our hands will be we will be
hamstrung as a department
if that in fact is true and if every law
that we pass may have the opportunity
has to be followed to the letter of the
law then I would ask why am I seeing a
solid waste report
in 2021 that by law was supposed to be
updated in I believe 2008.
and I think we are I mean I I think we
are using that argument to discredit
these stringent aspects of this law
which many people feel is has been more
than needed so
that's my frustration
thank you for your comments on that and
representative
thank you madam chair
um director wimsat
with the focus on groundwater which to
me is is
extremely important because groundwater
feeds everything whether it be surface
water whatever in its precipitation that
creates a lot of our surface water as
does the ground water
and as you stated by monitoring the
groundwater you're also monitoring the
surface water is that a correct
statement
certainly the groundwater data is very
relevant to nearby surface water quality
certainly and but I will point out that
we do have a number of landfills that
are situated in proximity to rivers and
we do monitor the river water quality as
well so there's monitoring in both the
groundwater and the river river water
follow-up thank you madam chair
so even though our rules are older
we are continually monitoring and if my
understanding is correct
um
you would like to see a two-year study
done
to make sure that we Encompass our our
geological differences in New Hampshire
compared to other states to make sure we
properly implement the rules and the
legislation to make this the best
possible we can is that correct yes we
we believe that the study the other
another bill that does propose that a
study be done would be really helpful to
us it's clear to us that that folks are
very concerned about the current status
of our surface water setback criteria
and our citing criteria and there's a
lot of of looking around at neighboring
states and their specific requirements
um and that's a complicated business
because whenever you look at rules or
the law in another jurisdiction it's
those have to be read in the context of
that that jurisdiction's entire body of
Law and rules so it's not just a simple
oh well they do this so we could do the
same thing and we believe that review of
our current rules and and the way that
we Implement Implement them along with
the review of neighboring states
approaches to this would be very helpful
and informative to the department as it
embarks on uh proposing new rules that
that would address citing criteria
thank you representative Knapp
um one
recognize that the 200 feet is a minimum
I also in my experience feel that if a
developer or business wants the minimum
they will do everything in their power
to get the minimum and they will throw
law into the lawyers into that they will
throw their own experts into that and I
feel like this bill gives CES a little
bit more coverage to be able to say that
they want a further setback I don't I
hope no one in this room thinks 200 feet
is an appropriate minimum because I
certainly don't
um the second thing I'll say is that
representative datsey made a really good
point last week that you we can find a
hydrogeologist I think to say we need a
mile and a hydrogeologist to say 200
feet is fine and the process of going
through this two-year study seems to
involve an RFP that hires a consultant
that makes recommendations and I'm
really concerned that we could easily
find a hydrogeologist that says
everything's fine as it is let's leave
it and I don't think this committee
wants to be in that place in two years
of having a recommendation coming back
to us that's it's fine as it is let's
leave it as it is I don't think that
people are comfortable with that and
that's my concern turn with the
alternative process that has been laid
out in doing a two-year study it's
pushing this down the road when we've
had 30 years to get a better process
thank you representative Murray uh thank
you madam chair and uh to to your point
I I think that we also want to make sure
that we are
giving the state the opportunity like
you had mentioned to have a little bit
more clarity in in statute as well as
the protection for the people who are
out here asking for protection of their
in statute of their water quality and
their water to represent a contrast
Point groundwater is important and I
think that folks before this committee
several times have said if we don't have
clean water
we don't have much of anything else
and I think that that's really what
we're asking for to be the focus here
when we're asking for
um something to be put in statute versus
rules
representative Creighton
thank you madam chair and thank you
director wimsat for your your comments I
just
not really just a statement in my mind I
live on a river my business involves
fresh water and fishing and all that and
so we we drink our own well water so I'm
well aware of the importance of that
what I don't want to do though is rush
to failure and what I'm hearing from
from the director is that there are
we have a direct interest in maintaining
Safe Water
but what I don't want to do is jump to
push the button and have unintended
consequences to where we say hey do this
and all of a sudden it's like well you
told us to do that well how come why did
this happen well I don't think we have
enough information to say that if we
push the button
that something that we don't intend to
happen will happen and and I know you've
been a lot longer than I have I got it
ma'am I got it I'm I'm new I was on Rod
last year so I but what I don't want to
do is punch that button and then a bunch
of stuff happens that I don't want to
have happen yes ma'am all right sure
representative datsey
thank you madam chair we have been
dealing with this for a long time and I
think
were some of us who have been on this
committee I mean it's really head
scratching to see what we went through
for two years and the representatives
that we had who jump through hoops to
make this a good bill and it was a good
bill and it had a great Bic partisan
support in the house last year we even
overrode the governor's veto and all of
a sudden the same bill
and the only changes that were made were
to appease the governor okay so it's the
it's basically the same bill and all of
a sudden we're getting all of this
pushback and it seems to me the only
reason we're getting the pushback is
that there's another bill in the works
that would allow the can to be kicked
down the road two more years and so you
know uh with all due respect I I
honestly don't think we're rushing to
judgment a lot of work I wasn't involved
in it but a lot of work was done on this
bill in the past two years
thank you representative I just want to
add one thing is that my my issue is
regarding and and I think there's a lot
of really good positive aspects
of this bill and its Amendment but I'm
really
I'm really torn with a statement that
was made by um Nikki Dillard Roy one of
the people who testified who said that
use and consideration of a single
highest measurement is not
representative of a real field geologic
hydrogeologic conditions
and and I believe uh director wimsat had
also
um alluded to that
I I'm I'm
just wondering if if by putting that in
place
we are then eliminating a lot of sites
that would be appropriate and um
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um to that point uh you know I I
understand your perspective and that is
Food For Thought when we're thinking
about this but I also happen to wonder
if if not taking
um when you look at other things like
standards for other types of safety
measures they often err on the side of
caution and public health and safety
first and put into protection the the
um
highest level of safety first and I
think that to that end that's what we're
asking to make sure that we have because
we don't
the EPA doesn't say these might you know
liners might leak it's as if and when
they will leak and I think that we want
to make sure that we have that five
years of that buffer so that we're never
dealing with another situation like this
and so to that end uh Madam chair I
respectfully
um posit that as food for thought as
well representative nav
um I just had one other comment which is
to piggyback on what representative
Murray was saying to me I think you know
your first thing is making sure these
things don't leak right that's the most
important thing and then the second
thing is making sure if they do leak
which they will that we have enough time
to work on it and the third piece is
monitoring and there's been a lot of
emphasis from the Des about the
monitoring and Remediation but you know
I live in a town with a pfest problem no
one talks about cleaning up the pfas
they talk about giving people point of
entry Water Systems you can't put these
things back once they've gotten out and
in a landfill you're talking about not
just pfas but heavy metals and other
contaminants that there's no real
remediation you cannot get these things
back into the landfill once they are in
your soil and your water it's impossible
it's an impossible task so you know
monitoring and Remediation are important
but to me they're sort of the last piece
and here we are addressing the middle
piece of what happens when there is a
leak and how much time do we have to
address it and how how many ways can we
consider protecting our water bodies of
water
thank you thank you representative
datsey
thank you madam chair yeah I mean I
think we're in a real Dilemma on this
um if I would look at this bill and I
would basically say we have a major
stakeholder which is des and I would say
bring Des into the into the fold and and
have them make suggestions but from what
I've been hearing is des does not feel
that it has the expertise in order to do
that so we're left with the situation
that you have dueling
hydrogeologists
and we're getting conflicting
information
and and I will admit it's a it's a real
dilemma I think for this committee to
try to figure out what the right formula
is is very difficult but the fact of the
matter is these dueling hydrologists for
the last two years have been battling it
out and this is the bill that we came up
with that was passed and since Des has
already said it does not have the
expertise to properly
um advise us on this why not go forward
with this bill and laws can be changed
and if it doesn't work out and if it's
hamstrung I think this committee would
be very willing to come back you know to
listen to Des based on the experience
that they're now having because it's in
all of us our best interests to cite
these landfills in the most appropriate
way and I mean I don't think we want to
be
work you know we don't want to be
working with against Des we want to be
working with you but if the expertise
isn't there
and clearly we're not defining any
expertise we have dueling expertise I
would say go forward with the bill and
make changes if needed and we've done
that you know we do that on an annual
basis with other bills representative
Howard
thank you madam chair um I we all
received a rather impassioned email from
a a
constituent and one of the points that
she made I I share and that is that
regulation is about this is to quote her
about being protective of the
environment and there's nothing wrong
with using the maximum value measured
for a calculation
um I I think you know to the point
that's been made earlier
um
shouldn't we when it comes to protecting
the environment and human health
shouldn't we be airing on the side of
caution
representative germano
thank you madam chair and I I have a
question that I was thinking about last
week as well and it connects with some
of the points that I agree with that
that representative Creighton has raised
I always want to have as much uh data
you know to to work with as possible to
make sure that our laws are based as
much as they can be in in solid science
no pun intended but
um what I'm wondering about when we talk
about if we take a rule that applies say
in the state of Maine or a law in the
state of Maine we apply it in New
Hampshire I understand that if we look
at 602 I think that's an example where
there's a lot of language in that it's
very deeply embedded in statute and rule
in Maine there's a case where I think
that would be problematic in this case
though the question I have in terms of
what kinds of information we would hope
to get from more hydrogeological studies
and perhaps you can can explain to me
why I'm confused about this or or
correct me
if I'm wrong for for given types of
of say Bedrock or clay or gravel and I
apologize for my highly inaccurate and
you know user geological terms but isn't
there there there's kind of a value in
the sense of if we describe something as
bedrock
it has a certain defined value in terms
for example of how quickly water is
going to move through bedrock as opposed
to clay or gravel or silt
Etc right the composition the density
Etc of that layer of Earth has a
particular value and I don't believe
that that value is different in Maine
than it is in New Hampshire our strata
may be different right so when we drill
we're going to find different amounts of
Bedrock clay silt gravel Etc but the
value that we would use to calculate the
seepage velocity is not going to be
different in main Bedrock as it is in
New Hampshire Bedrock so I have a
difficult time understanding how more
hydrogeological studies are going to
change those basic facts which brings me
back to the belief that that velocity
from the source to the groundwater
measured in time is a much more accurate
way of measuring setback than distance
which as you all know you've heard me
say a few times is actually a measure of
time so am I mistaken in saying that
different types of
Earth have different values in terms of
water transmission and that's not going
to be different in Maine than in New
Hampshire well actually
um I mean first of all I've acknowledged
I think in Prior questions and answers
um that
the idea of using time of travel is not
agency doesn't have to necessarily have
any objection to that
to go to your first question about you
know even Bedrock Bedrock how fast or
whether water moves through bedrock is
different depending on the bedrock in in
bedrock in New Hampshire is different in
different places in New Hampshire in
some places very little water will move
through it if it's very competent rock
with very low levels of fracturing other
areas where it may be very weathered and
fractured water may move very readily
through bedrock so it is very
site-specific even if you have a
particular type of medium whether it's
Bedrock or till or shell or or um or
gravel or sand all of those things have
a range of hydraulic conductivity
they're still
till they're still Bedrock but there may
be a wide range of hydraulic
conductivity in a particular unit so it
is very specific to the formation and to
the particular site so just just to be
clear on that
um so when I've spoken previously about
concerns about using rules from another
state you know we we haven't done a lot
of analysis on this but our staff have
spent some time talking with staff from
the state of Maine and it isn't clear to
me that that that rule the rules that
are that are being cited here and and
suggested for inclusion in New Hampshire
are necessarily implemented in Wayne in
Maine in the way that this committee
thinks they are because there are other
factors that are different about our
rules and it occurs it appears to us and
again this is based on a minimal amount
of analysis and and communication that
in reality
um the way those rules are constructed
and the way they're implemented doesn't
really result in the result that I think
this committee is expecting from that
and and by that I mean that uh the the
kinds of uh allowances
um for uh for the time of travel in
Maine maybe things that that are already
required by New Hampshire rules that
would not get you any additional time of
travel allowance in New Hampshire
um and that
um the variance opportunities that they
have for various requirements are not
opportunities that exist in New
Hampshire law so it's just all I was
trying to say from that is that it's
very hazardous to just take a particular
set of rules
from another state and drop them into
another State's entire legal and Rule
law and Rule Paradigm because you can't
always
you you can't be sure that the result
will be what you think it is it takes a
lot of analysis for that the agency
um does believe that it has the uh
expertise and the ability to evaluate
this question but we do think we need a
couple years to do it right and we would
like to have the additional benefit of a
third party taking an Eyes Wide Open
look at our rules in neighboring states
rules and giving us opinions on that we
may not agree with those opinions or are
we very likely we would take some of
them and maybe discard others because we
don't find them to be valid you know I
don't want to judge a study before it's
been done but
um we think that that
um
in order to do the careful analysis to
and to to arrive at a place where we all
can say we have a set of citing rules
with respect to surface water setbacks
that are appropriate and protective in
New Hampshire we think it's going to
take some time to do that properly
representative Murray
thank you in the interest of time and
seeing where the time is at I would just
like to say that it is my opinion that
this is actually very pro-business in
the sense that it makes it very clear
about where to even begin looking to
start an initial point of citing through
exploration because this is actually
requiring a third-party hydrogeologist
to take a look at where the siding would
meet that five-year distance travel and
if that isn't met then they can look
elsewhere immediately to begin
seeking an alternate more suitable place
to cite their landfill
thank you representative Haskins and
just a final comment
um
with respect this is not talking about
602 this is an attempt to update uh a
situation which is a 30 year old Rule
and there is going to be pressure to
cite a landfill
in other areas that perhaps we have not
had to deal with before so this is
protective this is an update
to study it is to definitely Kick the
Can down the road because we have been
here before and we're trying to give the
department a standard which we believe
can be met and will be protective and
the department can spend the time
developing the rules to follow
what the statute will say
thank you thank you representative
Compton did you have a question no no
um
so
I I know we don't want to talk about
this other bill that we haven't even
read yet that's supposedly coming from
the other side of the wall
um
but I mean there I would think that
there is really nothing that says that
um you know both bills wouldn't be
appropriate I mean we could we could put
something into statute now and have some
other studies being done in in tandem
and then come back and after these
studies are done and re-examine what we
have in statute and make appropriate
changes is that what's anybody's
thoughts on that
yeah okay
um
in the interest of time I I think that
we want to end this work session unless
anybody has anything other significant
points to make I know we've talked about
this to death already
I am going to
recess the community close the work
session recess this committee so that um
our our appropriate sites can caucus and
also give representative Murray some
time to go down to OLS and make the
appropriate change to the amendment for
HB 253 so I am going to request that um
uh everybody clear the rooms that we can
caucus about what we've heard this
morning
and then return
um well we were supposed to exec these
bills at 10 30. it's already 10 30. why
don't we
um uh come back at 11 o'clock
and
um we can then proceed to
do the exec on those two bills
uh and afterwards we will have a
presentation by some guests that we have
today from CSG so we will see you all
back at 11 o'clock
so representative Alexander
and I guess there's uh yeah
foreign
so we've got representative Alexander
you're right there
right right where you're standing right
there
my other daughter
6 30 this morning was brought to the
hospital in Rochester she's got some
sort of infection she couldn't walk by
him so I've got a daughter at Boston
Children's and now a daughter and
freaking frisbee so oh my God I'm
totally not in the game of any of this
sorry to be honestly
the exec will take five ten minutes
sorry literally yeah
so I don't know enough about so how many
sites right now are reaching to our
water so so this is I know this is for a
site it's a potential site again okay
the existing land sites that are in
operation right now are not leaching
none of us
thank you
okay good morning and welcome back to
environment and agriculture committee
please everybody get your seats settled
down
and what I will do now is um
open up the exact session for HP 253
HB 253 establishing a committee to study
extended producer responsibility
representative Murray do you have a
motion
yes Madam chair on I'd like to speak to
the amendment a motion for the amendment
please sure uh and that is for um
Amendment
20230797h and I'd like to make a motion
of um to pass for the amendment
and I hear a second
Madam chair I second
thank you representative Creighton
seconds
would you like to speak to the amendment
yes ma'am thank you
um so yeah based on the work study
session that we just had I um made the
suggested changes we made sure that on
line 14 the word examine was corrected
and per the input we had eliminated
paragraph seven and simply changed the
language on line 24 to read and may
propose topics for further study
thank you for that
okay
uh any other discussion on this
amendment of
um0797h for HB 253
seeing none I direct the clerk to roll
uh call the roll on um the vote on this
amendment
thank you madam chair where the motion
is to adopt Amendment
2023079 H for house bill 253.
represent Creighton yay representative
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Healy yes represent Pratt
yes represent coulon represent Kenny
yeah representza yes remember that smart
representative
represent Cahill yes represent dutse yes
yes represent Murray
yes
yes representative Haskins yes represent
Howard
yes Madam chair yes 20-0 motion passes
thank you do I hear emotion
representative Murray
oh representative Dotsy sorry uh yes uh
Madam chair I would like to move otpa on
uh HB 253 and I would like to commend
the committee on the discussion I think
we made it a better Bill and I'm hopeful
it will pass thank you do I hear a
second
Madam sure I second thank you
representative Creighton would you like
to speak to your motion representative
Dotsy
uh no I think everything's been said I
think this is an important bill and it's
a first step in having us look at how we
can reduce
um
debris going into the landfill and
um thank you very much
okay any other further discussion on
this amendment and this bill
seeing none I'd like to direct the clerk
to please call the roll thank you madam
chair we're voting otpa on House Bill
253 with Amendment
2023079h representative Creighton yay
representative yes representative
Alexander yes representative Healy yes
represent Pratt yes represent coulon
reps and Kenny representative Potenza
yes representative smart represents off
Akitas represent Cahill
yes represent dutse
represent Murray yes Robin jamana yes
president Haskins yes representative
Howard yes represent NAB represent Morse
representative yes Madam chair yes 20-0
motion passes
without objection I'd like to place this
on consent
okay it'll be on consent thank you very
much
with that I will close the exact session
for HP 253
and I will open up the exact session on
HB 56
do I hear motion
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I'd like to move amendments
20230772 h
to house bill 56.
do I hear a second
oh representative Dotsy
would you like to speak to your
Amendment please yes yes Madam chair I
would thank you very much
um so
um folks had worked incredibly hard over
the last several years to come up with
what we felt was an appropriate response
to setting policy in statute to protect
our water and ground resources and to
that end we have for the most part kept
the original Bill intact and worked in
good faith to get buy-in from various
stakeholders that would support the bill
and that is the effort that you see
before us in zero seven seven two h
thank you do I hear any other discussion
about this amendment
yes we did representative
any other discussion about this
amendment
okay seeing none
um
I would like to have the role called a
vote thank you madam chair we're voting
to adopt Amendment
20230772h representative Creighton name
represent no representative Alexander no
representative Healy no representative
Pratt no represent coulon
represent Kenny represent Potenza no
represents smart
representative
representative Cahill yes represent
dutse yes yes represent Murray yes
president jamana yes
represent Haskins yes represent Howard
yes represent NAB
represent Morse represent Voit yes Madam
chair no
10 10 motion fails
okay so that brings us back to the
original Bill uh do I hear a motion on
that bill representative Murray uh yes
Madam chair I would like to propose a
motion about to pass on House Bill 56.
do I hear a second
thank you representative Dotsy
um any discussion on the underlying bill
and um this is our position that um
we feel that there is a need for
protection in statute to make sure that
our groundwater is um
clearly and definitively protected thank
you representative Contour thank you
madam chair
um I believe the Des is doing a good job
with what they're doing in monitoring we
are constantly their rules state that we
are to monitor the groundwater
which is extremely important
and we know that other states who have
this five-year travel setback
do not require double liners as does the
State of New Hampshire and we know that
they have a lot of exceptions in their
rules which if we put this into statute
will not will tie the hands of Des and
the rulemaking authority
thank you representative representative
Creighton
uh yes ma'am I agree completely that we
need to protect our groundwater
and I believe that we should act to do
so but I do believe that this is a case
of ready fire aim and that we need to
save more time and figure out exactly
how we do that silver
representative Howard
I think the preceding statutes for that
covering this um this area are 30 years
old there's a lot of Science in the last
30 years and a lot of discovery of
things that we didn't even know about 30
years ago that we need to protect
against and I think that we need to take
steps now to update the law
representative Potenza
I agree with what she's saying um but I
know that there is a bill that's coming
from the Senate and because of that in
regards with redundancy I believe that
uh that we should focus on that which is
coming down the pike soon and it's
better and well written representative
Murray
point of order if I may yes
on the bills before this committee if I
may sure yes
we shouldn't really be uh thinking or
talking about bills that may or may not
come to this committee
um and and I believe that that's a valid
point to bring up so I just want to
remind our our members here
um
did you want to say anything else no
representative
for the years that I've been here
people have come to this committee for
um remedy
or problems
um inciting landfills
and they keep coming up empty
this
I just
the people of New Hampshire are our
stakeholders they they ask us to come
here to do a job and I might act like
I'm I'm not involved in what's going on
but this is like the maybe the fourth
time I've been through this process
I have been up to the North country and
I have toured those landfills and the
people came
for help
and we can't just keep saying oh well
we're gonna study it or we're going to
have some other thing it's not they need
protections and they need us to make a
decision the fact that Des
was so far behind in giving this Solid
Waste plan to us
years and years and years behind
I guess I just asked to you to think
about
when the damage is done it's we it's
like trying to put the toothpaste back
into a toothpaste tube
it's a very very difficult job we have
one high cancer clusters in this state
and we can tout really uh Liberty we can
Tout
lack of regulations we can
um deregulate everything but things
don't come
the way of the small people
the of these small towns who don't have
um big budgets to protect themselves and
so I just would ask
that
this is the third time I have heard this
bill and I would really ask people
to think in their hearts
about
your children your grandchildren
and instead of thinking about a company
or a business
think about the cancer clusters
thank you
okay
representative smart
um I I
think that
um
I agree with protection and
making you know what once something
happens it's too late kind of thing I
agree with that but I think that things
need to be site-specific I think they'll
one size fits all is not the way to go
when it comes to this I think it's the
the land is too diverse things are the
area is too diverse and I think we need
to have a more
diverse Bill rather than one size fits
all That's Mike representative Haskins
thank you madam chair I agree with that
also
um I do think that this bill gives Des a
standard I believe that they can meet it
I believe the rulemaking needs to meet
the standard I believe that we can
respect the work that's gone into this
that it was essentially a bipartisan
bill that was passed and I I can't
understand why we want to roll back
protection and go backwards
so I support the bill strongly thank you
representative germano
thank you madam chair uh and and with
respect genuinely man respect to to
Senator uh representative Smart's point
about site's need for site-specific
information I would argue this is
site-specific right you do tests on
specific sites and what in the end uh
happens is based upon the science that
is conducted with site-specific tests
um I also want to uh
piggyback on something representative
safikidus pointed out is the argument
that she made that in the end we have to
decide who it is that we are
representing on this committee uh and in
the house and and I think if if we do
that then the answer should always be to
err on the side of caution particularly
given some of the hard lessons
um Granite Staters have already learned
about these issues and finally I would
say that with the question about further
studies we have had ample time to
conduct these studies Des has had ample
time to conduct these studies this is
not a new conversation
um it is time for the legislature to act
because uh what we've seen is over and
over again kicking the can down the road
for various reasons none of which I
think are ultimately sustainable so the
studies that should have been done
already should have been done apparently
they haven't been and it's time for the
legislature to take action to put this
into statute and to follow through to
make sure that Pro appropriate actions
are taken thank you thank you
any other questions or comments
I just want to say first of all
I want to thank this committee for all
of the diligence the questions
thought-provoking comments that have
been made and made in a very civil and
helpful manner
um
we we've worked hard on this I know
representative Murray worked very hard
on this and I want to thank you for all
the work that everybody on this
committee has put in on to this
particular issue it's not an easy issue
um
and you know when it comes down to
creating legislation something that's
going to be law
it's it's daunting for all of us I think
to really
um make that consideration and say yes
this is what should be
and I think with that we have you know
been very very careful in our thoughts
on dealing with this
um and and anybody who is voting against
this bill it's not because
they don't want to see
um you know clean water or they don't
want to see a
you know horrible things have they they
you know they they want all good things
to happen
um Des also wants to do things right and
do it in the best way possible
and I think that
um we want to make sure that we have
state law that's not going to be binding
any agency's hands
and is going to give them the
flexibility that they need to deal with
situations
as they unfold in any particular
uh landfill citing
um issue
for me
this has been particularly difficult
because I do believe that change has to
be made
but I also want to be very careful with
the change that we do make
and my hesitation with this particular
legislation has really been
again the one size fits all
and making a prescriptive change
especially when it comes to you know
hydrogeological conditions which I know
very little about
I think that when we as a as a body
consider
using a single highest measurement that
may not be representative of the entire
site that we're treading into some very
difficult water
and so for me that is why
um I'm inclined not to vote Yes on this
bill but I
irrespective of that whatever my reasons
are
I think this committee has done an
amazing job an enormous job
considering all the pros and cons and I
want to thank you
with that
um
I direct the clerk to call the roll
please thank you madam chair this is
OTP on HB 56 representative 253 yeah 56
I'm sorry okay representative Creighton
may represent no representative
Alexander no representative Healy no
represent Pratt no represent coulon
represent Kenny represent Potenza no
represent smart
represents Sophie kedis represent Cahill
yes represent dutse yeah represent
Murray yes represent jamana yes
represent Haskins yes represent Howard
represent NAB represent Morse Rosen
Voigt yes Madam chair nay 10 10 no
recommendation
thank you in um
who wrote uh write the uh
for the OTP
report
and I will write against it okay thank
you
I appreciate again all the work this
committee has done on all of the bills
that we've had come before us
that
pretty much does it for all the bills
until we get anything from the Senate
side
and I am going to close out the um
exact session for HB 56
and I would like to invite our guests
to come up and speak to us today from
the Council of state governments
they are prior chairs of this committee
The Honorable Tara said
and um The Honorable Rob Hafner
yeah
Welcome to our committee and thank you
for sitting through a very uh
interesting morning it was interesting
to us
um we started in 2006 together we were
elected in 2006 and we always served on
this committee the entire 10 years we
were in the house and how many bills did
we have on landfill citing
Lots and we went through the same
process and you know it's sort of like
we were talking about kicking the can
down the road we were some of the ones
that kicked it one of the original ones
so
um we are sort of disheartened to see
that it's still here it's still a
subject and it hasn't been
fixed but you know someone earlier said
we've been discussing this for a long
while well we were discussing in 2006
right exactly
um it's a it's a tough tough tough issue
but one that is critically important to
the health and safety of the people in
the state so
um you did you guys did a great job I
mean the thoughtful thoughtful
um
thinking that went behind it is great so
anyway why we're here
um as we said I'm Tara sad this is Bob
Heffner I'm from Walpole
which is the prettiest town in the
entire State and one with more dairy
farms than any other town and
I can't hear you you have to say
yeah okay uh I'm from Hudson
and uh we she may have more dairy farms
but we've got better bottom land to
throw crops on
I'm on the Connecticut River which has
the best bottomland of any
we do this and have been doing it for 16
years now
um
after leaving the house we were asked to
join the Council of state governments
um does everyone know what council of
state governments is okay council state
government is a membership organization
that all the states in the country pay
membership dues to and because of that
we work for you we are the Agriculture
and Rural Affairs policy consultants for
the Eastern region so we have 11
Northeastern states from Maryland
Pennsylvania New York and all of New
England and five eastern Canadian
provinces and two territories Puerto
Rico and the Virgin Islands
it's fun to go to conferences down there
um especially in the winter time
what we do is we provide Research
Services for you if you need anything we
do conferences we do policy Summits but
the thing that we do most is we
introduce you to your compatriots in
other states
you get to know who the people are in
Vermont who are dealing with the same
issues pretty much that you are here and
finding out what they have done about it
looking to see any legislation that
would work here or tricks to solving a
problem because in the Northeast
Agriculture and Rural issues are pretty
much all the same
when we deal with
like ncsl is another organization
similar to us they're a National
Organization so if they deal with
agriculture they deal with Iowa they
deal with Oklahoma they deal with
California
their AG is completely different than
ours we're not a commodity region and so
we need to group together all of our 11
states and come up with legislation that
works for us and then Lobby the federal
government when they're dealing with the
farm bill which is in negotiations now
so that we are protected and we get what
we need
um in fighting the Iowa and the
Kansas's so anyway and to that point uh
when we combine our 11 states and speak
as a voice we've got 20 percent of
Congress so it it is in fact a voice uh
that that can compete with The
Californians of the world
there are important things coming up of
course in the farm bill number one the
nutrition title all of the SNAP benefits
the school lunches everything like that
it's huge and those are being negotiated
now so we need to watch out for our
citizens as far as what is included
there commodities
actually the um
specialty crops are included in that it
never was before so we have a voice
there for our small farmers who are
doing vegetables and fruits and things
like that instead of competing with the
soybeans and the corn
um
I I think the other thing that we really
should mention is
among things that we do Tara mentioned
that we'll do research for you and that
type of thing uh lobbying for the farm
bill in fact one year Tara and I took a
resolution from our committee and went
to a congressional hearing on the farm
bill and we we actually spoke to
Congress on that one and
left them with our resolution so there
is a voice but the the main thing I
think we do is and I think we do it
pretty well is we put on uh an annual
meeting in which our committee generally
tackles three topics at each one of our
annual meetings as well as taking some
kind of a tour usually Farms but it
could be something else
uh this past year we were here in
Manchester
we had a great five-day session in
Manchester and
um
the next one in August is going to be in
Toronto so if you would like to do some
international travel you may want to
think about that
but talking about our annual sorry
talking about our annual meeting we
always try to come up with topics that
our members want to hear about
so that we can decide
what to focus on what speakers to bring
in what experts to bring on to give us
information and make it worthwhile for
everyone to that end this afternoon
you're all going to be receiving an
email that has a little survey Link in
it it's I think there are like 10
questions or something like that just so
that you can choose from a list which
topics you think are most important to
you so that we can take that into
consideration when we're coming up with
speakers and the topics so if you
wouldn't mind I'd appreciate that a lot
what else and and I think the other
thing we'll mention is we also do policy
Summits uh we are in the process of
putting one together now that will be at
the end of April in Baltimore and uh
Tara will tell you it's a really nice
hotel and it is uh but this will be a
Friday afternoon and Saturday and we're
going to do a deep dive into uh labor
issues for both farms and processing
so we've got milk producers that will be
speaking we we've got the chicken
Council from Delaware and Maryland that
will be speaking on chicken processing
and farming uh We've we've got the
Huntington's coming from uh right up the
street here in Loudon who are one of the
biggest flower growers in the country
and and they hire 350 h2a workers a year
and they're going to come and talk about
their problems we've also got the U.S
Department of Labor coming I was an
expert on h2a and h2b labor and I've
probably missed oh we we've got the
secretary of agriculture from Maryland
coming
uh we have also invited the executive
director of the Maryland Farm Bureau and
uh a woman from rural Maryland uh who
can shed some information on the
problems with labor in the fishing
industry
yes
and you know Seafood farming as well so
so that's what we do
um we
enjoyed our 10 years here on this
committee we are sure and certain that
it is the best Committee in the house
and by watching you today that just
solidifies that fact that you it really
really is a good committee and
congratulations on being on it we hope
you enjoy it as much as we enjoyed being
on it and um
give us a call if you need anything and
look for the email that I'm sending and
fill out the survey
any questions
sure will thank you very much for
joining us this uh this morning it's a
pleasure to have you back in the house
thank you
and um
I'm interested to know when you guys are
each of you took chairmanship at one
point and sort of bounced it back
between party majority yes
um how many bills went through your
committee at a time I mean we we had 20
you know this when we first started out
it was in the 30s we had a lot of bills
for Ena and then sometimes it was like
12 and 11 and you wonder like are we
going to continue being a committee if
we have so few bills but then I see it's
it's cyclical it goes up and down and up
and down depending on what the issues
are
um and um
like I say it's it's it's amazing how
the same bills keep coming back over and
over and over again like landfills but
that's what keeps it interesting do you
have a sense of what a majority of bills
were I mean were you dealing more with
say cat and dog bills than you were with
and that was also that was also a
signature one of the big ones that we
had in our committee in our tenure was
GMOs GMOs that was huge that was huge
and painful because that was very
divisive and normally like before it you
know in the execs that we just heard
um it tends to be unanimous we had most
of our bills on the consent calendar
um because normally AG is not a partisan
issue thank heavens unlike other
committees where that's all they deal
with so yeah so Bob is a Republican and
I'm a democrat in case you didn't know
this and so back in the days every of
every year every election the majority
would switch and so we would just switch
chairs you know yeah
but we still worked again
even though he's wrong on it
like a married couple huh
he says the same amount yeah I don't uh
Tara mentioned uh the GMO bill uh that
got really national attention when it
was uh here and Tara and I were speaking
on the floor in opposition to the bill
both of us were uh and and it was a
partisan bill that Tara and I were in
agreement and we spoke in opposition to
it and we found out later that there
were people in Maine at the Farm Bureau
uh that were cheering us on from their
offices up in Augusta because they had
[Music]
Maine Banning GMOs or requiring labeling
and in order for Theirs to go through in
the bill it said that New Hampshire has
to pass this before ours will go through
it had to be you know the neighboring
state and so because we didn't pass
hours theirs were was not in effect
either
which left Vermont pretty much out there
on its own at the time that was a tough
one and then we also had animal cruelty
bills oh my gosh oh my gosh
that was the animal activist that would
come and testify and cry and you know I
mean
it was just really bad so including
coming from Nebraska oh yeah they came
all the way from Nebraska to testify
they were huge I mean people lined out
in the hallway waiting to testify big
big
um those were the main ones most of the
time it is Small Things
um but important to agriculture into the
area which is great
um yeah it's the best committee
anything else does anybody have any
questions for our guests
representative Haskins I'll see you in
Toronto are you coming oh good good good
good good oh we're gonna have fun yes I
know I know the trouble is for our tour
you know our field trip it takes about
two hours to get outside of Toronto
because it's such a big city and traffic
is so bad so I think we're going to wind
up going to the huge huge huge farmers
market downtown Toronto which will be
fun I know right they'll be good looking
forward to it and it'll be good
and so you're going to help us determine
what you're going to be listening to
good thank you representative
anyway any other questions comments from
the committee no thank you very much for
joining us this morning
um
we appreciate your time good thank you
thank you oh we're going to be back
again with the whole organization we
just wanted to come because the
committee sure on the 20th and 21st 20th
to 21st so if you see us in the Halls
you just say hi okay and thank you so
much for your past service to the state
in the legislature for your current
um take care it's all volunteer all
right thank you
so with that we've uh We've Ended early
today and again I want to thank
everybody for their their work and um
and their attention due diligence
appreciate it I'm sure representative
germano thank you madam chair I just I
found out I don't know if anyone else
had heard this just found out that
representative partial who is sponsored
the extended producer responsibility
Bill uh had a heart attack after the
last house session and uh went into
actually went into cardiac arrest in the
ambulance afterwards and he is uh he's
at home recovering he plans to be here
on uh on on Thursday but if you if you
know uh representative partial or you
know want to reach out to him and and
and check in with him I only just found
that out because I texted him to let him
know about his bill
um going on the consent calendar and and
just found out so anyway you see him on
Thursday or if you send him an email or
something just to let him know you're
thinking of them thank you thank you
all right with that we're adjourned
appreciate it
is
yeah yeah I'm gonna send something to
Jamie
thank you madam chair and I wanted to
give you this because you're you're
coming
this Invitational you need to come
we'll get you there so
thank you okay I'm going to send you the
link to register okay
all right thank you it's a pleasure to
meet you nice to meet you Jim Brady yes
Paris
I guess I'm going to Baltimore yes
yeah
uh here
here
thank you
thank you I appreciate it
okay so we're done
okay so I've got a
that's good
you know
okay
your face
what's happening
yeah
thank you
foreign
okay
thank you
yeah
foreign